der hyper look funktioniert ein erster
großversuch ist auf der 500 meter langen
teststrecke der flut gelungen zum ersten
mal wurde direkt zwei dinge gleichzeitig
erreichten des chores wurde ein vakuum
hergestellt und ein fahrgestell wurde
darin mit der von hyperdoc wann
genutzten magnetschwebetechnik zum
abheben gebracht klicks um
science-fiction herz bekommen
kritiker werfen dem hyper luke projekt
immer wieder vor eigentlich nicht
funktionieren das vakuum können nicht
hergestellt werden die geschwindigkeit
zu hoch deshalb weil es zu gefährlich es
gebe keine infrastruktur und so weiter
und so fort doch immer mehr werden die
kritiker durch tatsachen ihren
argumenten beraubt ist der erste goal
versuch gelungen
zum einen wurde in der 500 meter langen
teststrecke ein vakuum erzeugt
das heißt nicht mehr und nicht weniger
das eine strecke unter vakuum gesetzt
wurde
die mit zahlreichen röhren elementen und
damit zahlreichen verbindungsstellen an
den risse und undichtigkeiten entstehen
können versehen ist es spricht also
vieles dafür dass damit auch auf den
noch grösseren massstab geschlossen
werden kann
das heißt dass es möglich ist dass auch
auf einer langen strecke von mehreren
hundert oder sogar tausend kilometern
ein vakuum hergestellt werden können wir
wie sagt es ist also schon mal bestanden
check und auch die magnetschwebetechnik
die bei haifa logan eingesetzt werden
soll
funktioniert unter diesen bedingungen
geheimer loop würde so nahezu ohne
reibung weder durch luft noch durch die
antriebstechnik durch die röhre raten
der energieverbrauch durch den antrieb
wäre extrem niedrig und warum ist das
alles nötig die idee des hyper luke ist
im prinzip super simpel
er funktioniert wie eine rohrpost und
sie könnte der magnetschwebetechnik
jetzt im nachhinein zum erfolg verhelfen
das prinzip der zug oder beim haifa lob
eine kapsel wird in eine röhre gepackt
und in der herrscht ein vakuum bzw ist
kaum noch luft enthalten ein sogenanntes
hochleistungspumpen pumpen die luft aus
der röhre und erhalten das vakuum der
effekt es gibt keinen luftwiderstand
mehr oder noch sehr gering
das hauptproblem und der energiefresser
dieses schnellen transport ist einfach
weg und damit brauche ich für den zug
kaum noch energie ist 3 mal beschleunigt
es sollen solarzellen auf den
transporteuren ausreichen um für die
energie zu sorgen hat
magnetschwebetechnik wird dabei das
elektro dynamische schwebe system
eingesetzt dabei sind im fahrweg
herkömmlichen magnetspulen eingebaut und
dem fahrzeug magnet wo
den supraleiter im vergleich zum
transrapid ist der abstand zwischen den
magnetspulen größer es werden also
weniger günstig nachteil der fraport
schwebt erst an einer ganz bestimmten
geschwindigkeit vorher benötigt es
stützräder umfahren von können vorteil
des systems wird bereits beim japanische
magnetschwebebahn kleff eingesetzt als
höchstgeschwindigkeit wurden damit sogar
schon 630 kilometer pro stunde erreicht
ohne vakuum und jetzt scheint es auch
richtig voran zu gehen
in den vereinigten arabischen emiraten
haben die planungen für die erste
strecke zwischen dubai und abu dhabi
begonnen die lufthansa soll sich für das
projekt votiert ein großteil des
flugverkehrs würde so ersetzt werden und
zusätzlich soll der flug auf der strecke
doppelt so schnell sein wie ein flugzeug
ich bin extrem gespannt ob und wie
schnell das konzept umgesetzt werden
kann
mehr über den heimflug und die deutschen
pläne gibt es hier darf hier
draufklicken wenn ihr kein video mehr
verpassen wollten ja hier ein abo
auftauche und vergesst nicht gehen auch
die blogger ansonsten gesund bleibt